[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Spotify so my name is Neville
and here's my contract so let's start so
little bit about me I met Spotify since
2011 like shortly after we just launched
new yours
I'm right now a member so we do a lot of
like Hadoop jobs machine learning jobs
and we figure out what you like what you
listen to and what you should be
listening to hopefully and we are mostly
- potato in the back end so they talk
infrastructure like pipeline and tools
and a little bit back and be bailing
terabytes of data terabytes of
recommendation to our users every day
and I I started using a bunch of really
nice tools for date doing theater stuff
so among them we do storm that's for
real-time processing what sort of
scouting which is a scholar rapper for
cascading so you can do like basically
have a higher abstraction layer on top
of MapReduce we also started to use
spark which is a memory high-performance
computation energy that works really
well for some of the iterative machine
learning jobs like matrix factorization
or gradient descent and we all group at
least do a lot of Scala it's interesting
language it's very cool but as its pain
points among those things well qualify
everyone that likes music
so I also likes music I like music and
that's actually me playing a lefty
guitar and if you follow the Spotify
blog I also did very of visualization
hack a while ago it's a JavaScript heck
for visualization y'see your audio later
so that's really bit about me
so Spotify everyone knows about Spotify
hopefully we music company with stream
free music to users there's also premium
where you get
of my music and I used also catch ads
free experience here's what if I in
numbers basically were available in 55
markets right now and we're growing
pretty quickly and have a lot of songs a
lot of user data that we collect every
day and we have huge amount of user
generated playlists basically user
creates all these music and then we try
to mine them and figure out the
relationship between music and between
you know users that's what different
numbers so we also like big data
obviously this is actually our second
generation cluster this one over here
sync it overheated and somehow crashed
that was awhile ago we went through a
few generations already we wore a dress
for world had our own cluster it went
from 200 notes to right now I think it's
700 it's one of the biggest Hadoop
clusters in Europe let's try this one
much better redundancy here yeah that's
why you always need backup
all right yes oh really we handle a huge
amount of data with a and 5,000 sort of
drops running every day I think we
thought this recommendation team
contribute to maybe hundreds of a
thousand of them and we are team alone
generates maybe a hundred terabytes a
day of data so what is then in layman's
terms esse that's how we describe it to
two people inside Spotify that just
started using storm so it's a real-time
processing is left in batch and it's
similar to other except this nor HDFS so
you kind of have to send out data like
input and output or self so it can be
anything c'mere a real-time stream from
cough calls on message queue and could
a database and can eventually write it
out to some database or some some output
stream which can be another Kafka
cluster and like MapReduce you have some
kind of tuples aggregation and stuff but
you can have many reducer jobs I think
of all the parts where you can chain
them together you can really compost
interesting application out of reusable
small components whereas you know each
part just capture some inputs to some
processing computation and generate some
outputs and a topology is basically a
network of such parts connected together
and there's there are a few other things
that's really nice like for tolerance
and guaranteed messaging processing and
delivery so basically you can add
messages and you can handle failure
failure senior's apology seems like that
so its introduction to storm and it's
move on so storm and Spotify we're
actually using a fairly old version of
storm it's point eight zero and we have
a twenty two node cluster that's
independent from a loop cluster they are
running right like right next to each
other in the same data center right now
we have 15 topologies running in
production
most of them doing some kind of tracking
monitoring or analytics and some of them
actually supporting product features and
I'm gonna cover some of them later in
this talk so the applications include
recommendation or these three ads
targeting monitoring and analytics so
everyone knows what this song this is
this is actually one our first storm
application that was late 2012 and it's
a newer time of real-time map of the
zone by react actually I think he made a
lot of money out of Spotify from this
song yeah so it's a pure map of showing
people listening to that track in real
time
and the next one I kind of grayed out
the numbers I'm not sure if they're like
shareable but this is a mock market
launch dashboard this is when we are
doing the sauce American lunch so you
can see all these countries on the top
row and then this all these different
platforms different features so whenever
we launch in a couple of new markets
there's usually a war room with dev QA
operations they said to the other ghosts
it's like a complicated chain of steps
to to initiate a new market like PR
campaign open up user registration open
up Facebook open up iTunes and Google
App Store downloads and all that stuff
so having real-time numbers for tracking
what's going on how many users are
coming every second that's really
helpful so that's one of the internal to
Louise spaced on storm data and from
Kafka and too strong other users we have
a few other users one of them is
training track that's used internally
for figuring out what's popular right
now last 5-10 minutes what's
increasingly getting traction like based
on the number of user playbacks and
stuff we also do a lot of email
campaigns where we send emails to users
and key attract the click through and
delivery rate and all that kind of stuff
that's also tracked via storm and then a
bunch of application or user experience
tracking like they don't see how how
many milliseconds it takes to start a
track how many milliseconds it takes to
load a viewer page and those kind of
stuff so we we do a lot of analytics
stuff on storm so questions so far
feel free to interrupt me and ask
questions so in the next section I'm
gonna just dig into one of the stone
topologies that we do here that's
actually powering a social feature so
it's from from a user's plate all the
way up to the recommendation I'm gonna
dig into all these different components
in a storm topology and here's the thing
about Spotify since we have a fairly
big group cluster and we also we've been
doing MapReduce and data analysis for a
while
storm is not really we don't really use
storm as a way of doing small batch I
mean I've been to a couple of companies
here since it seems that it's one of the
pretty popular use case for doing small
batch data analytics with that but we
also do most of them are Hadoop and for
us storm is really a good way of
building distributor brocation that's
doing soft real-time use the experience
of features like that yeah and let's
look at this feature the one we're gonna
talk about is social listening so your
firm listen to some truck and it shows
up in your feet this is the first
generation we all have friends like that
you know just keep jamming on one truck
and it's annoying so that's the first
generation on again it's kind of a
love-hate relationship Facebook tried
out a while ago to have the buddy feed
that keeps popping users hated they turn
it off I think they just turn it back on
like last week or something so it's not
back there again
so this is porch without any data
analytics tools it's just using back in
pub/sub messaging so it is fairly real
time since prop up almost like within
sub second latency that's really spammy
we don't do anything smart with the
recommendation there's no recommit we
just try to deliver every message to the
user so it's not super interesting and
the engagement rate is pretty low and
also it's really hard to scale because
the messaging part and we use cell and Q
actually and and with four data centers
and like maybe tens of thousands of
messages or a second it's really hard to
scale the second shake just one we
actually did it on Hadoop with daily
batches so basically we collect data
every day and the end of the day we
generate some Hadoop jobs goes through
what the users have listened to over the
last 24 hours or seven days generally
some kind of aggregation or discuss
doesn't mean a lot to this truck the
problem is it takes too long to show up
it takes more than 20
was the nobody that just kind of goes
goes away and also noticed this story
oops sorry
this there's no time stamp on it
because we don't I mean it's too late
it's not interesting to show the time
stamp so this is the second take it is
easier to scale though because you just
add more machines but then at the same
time every day there's just thousands of
jobs spawning up at the same time after
midnight because of the daily analytics
you know rush and that kind of breaks
down once in a while so the current take
we actually collect data using Kafka we
collect data from also the production
machines feed them into stone stones or
some kind of computation and then all
the ways and throw it to a pack in that
way we can do incremental updates
basically we just compute a state
accounting and notice in this case which
we have a six minutes ago that's pretty
recent and interesting you can talk to
the guy uh characteristics like a few
maybe twenty feet from me
so what's interesting we discover these
kind of serendipitous moments a lot in
Spotify and it's fairly easy to scale
you have a bunch of ports and sports you
basically add more parallelism to each
layer as they grow and if each layers is
kind of isolated and it's there's good
it's it's very you can easily do
horizontally skellige so that's that's
what we like it and I'm gonna explain
this a little bit more yes
yes yes so let's use a listening to a
track and then it goes all the way
through the entire pipeline so from the
user playing so this is actually one can
talk about next so user plays attract
all the users involve actually connects
to this thing called access point that's
like a gateway we have some encryption
and it's so it's pretty beefy you have
like two or three hundreds of them
machines for handling just use a
connection and a playback they do all
the heavy lifting and they also track
all sorts of user log like player track
player edge click on something some app
event all sorts of log and behind that
there's all sorts of different backends
we have a SOA like service-oriented
architecture where here where we have a
lot of smaller system each handles
something really simple and for example
a playlist social switch storage so
these are the different kind of systems
and all these servers have Kefka produce
installed so they generate log and the
log goes to CAFTA so let's look at how
it actually works and
about logging so this is our whole log
looks like it's it's kind of hacky
actually it's legacy from a couple of
years ago we have this TSV type of log
but actually we we do version II and log
type of them so for example if you look
at these about your type of logs there's
a song version 21 this also find event
415 and oops
all right thanks yeah
so we have these sort of message types
and a lot and the version also have
converters in Python and Java so while
you can write your MapReduce job either
in JVM mode or in Python MapReduce and
pass the log and also have a centralized
repository for all sorts of message
types and we're actually moving to
Averell so these we actually include the
me into a schema Evaro type so next and
this is how data gets shipped across the
globe so in the middle of a big London
data center that's where clusters like
Hadoop cluster and a stone cluster lives
we also have Swasey smaller data centers
in Ashburn Virginia I think San Jose and
Stockholm so a service machine spoken
service machines on those clusters they
have Kafka paneer so they shipped data
to their local Kafka broker and then it
gets shipped to the big Kafka in in
London and then that guy looks at a log
splitter I mean by type and timestamp
and then ship them either to Hadoop
where you end up with you know territory
HDFS like crying event 2014 2014 like
April 1st and they are like 0 0 and
stuff and then in storm where you
capture these data are using Kafka spout
so
the topology that supports the real-time
listening kind of looks like this and of
course you have a cough Kasbah that
collects and sound data from user
whenever user listens to a track you
have an answer message that goes through
this spot and the first layer is a
filter which workers look at the end
song events and filter out the
interesting ones the second layer is a
metadata decorator
because in song a if you remember in the
previous slide we track user name
timestamp and the track ID but sometimes
we also want to know artist and album ID
so that guy decorates by looking up
making a get request to the metadata
service and that creates the data then
there's a listening trigger bot which
detects interesting patterns someone's
jamming like really in the loop or
someone's listening to a interesting
track and then extra we also value
privacy that's why we have a privacy
future basically if you have a set in
turn off like to not publish you don't
want your friends to see it Oh Neville's
Jamie with a cursory that's embarrassing
and so at the end of it there's a
publisher
we used a 0 mq transport protocol to
publish events through the network and
it's again it's a service-oriented
architecture where any kind of Soviets
can subscribe to this events stream so
we have a feedback in that subscribe to
it and then and serve it to the user in
your social feed so that's our
architecture this is actually rolled out
to a hundred percent of users right now
it's on discovery pages kind of mixed
with or the other type of
recommendations but we're looking at a
different ways of making it more
interesting and interactive like users
can actually like and play the track and
maybe it generates a feedback to the
original user or someone like you or
your story so any questions so far yes
okay the question is is there a reason
for using character for the input panel
for output more for the input because
it's already there and cascadas reliable
message delivery not for the output
because reliability is not like highest
concern in this case like if we don't
recommend a story user not gonna
complain so I mean yes optionally you
can use CAF card in the in the output
case as well but it's just a matter of
choice or design decision and for us
it's for this particular use case it's
okay to lose some recommendation some
cases maybe not if you're doing ads
targeting you don't want to lose ad
targeting opportunity right because then
you lose money so the first part is and
so on so it does something pretty see a
single like if the we actually keep
track of lot of attributes like if you
the user scape the track how many
milliseconds they use a skill or played
in a track I mean anything people lower
their thirty seconds it's not really
interesting and then we also have
contacts like if they use a plate in a
playlist view in a search bar that's
gonna me if the user search for the
track and play it that's very
interesting but if it's in radio maybe
not because it's just a random shuffle
track so these are the reasons and
context so we look at these and a few
roll certain certain events and next is
the metadata decoration bot so basically
this but gets some input fields and the
first thing it does is work up the track
ID by the doing this method on the on a
tuple and then and looks up the audience
and album ID and appendage to the to the
output tuple
so this is what we call a decorator and
we actually have to pass the input
fields into the constructor if you've
done storm or watching storm parts
before you have to declare the output
fields before you initializing or you
have to declare this method a lot
éclairs the output fields so you have
kind of have to know what your input
fields are we
but GU thing about it is it's really
reusable so whoever can just pick up
this ball to put it in their store to
apology and as long as you have this
track ID input you'll get additional to
address you know where the output this
is actually very similar to how scouting
or cascading does scenes to your tuples
basically have a tuple based records and
append feel to it and also it's if you
know functional programming it's this is
actually a melodic design it's basically
encapsulated the data in some kind of
abstraction and we have similar parts
like geoip decoration basically by
looking at the IP of ants on figure out
where the users from and host grassman
cache Kieran said so similar reusable
components that we have and inside this
is actually a little bit more complex
we're doing a synchronous requests and
we try to patch as many requests as
possible so if you look at this there
are actually two slots the approach
thread is the main saw where handles
tuples
there's also networks words from the the
RPC library that we use based on 0mk so
whenever a tuple come see it gets end up
in a batch because we want to delay the
request or make across all four hundred
trucks a time instead of one each time
and then it gets scheduled on the other
sweat and once you about you fill up
this they're sent over a network to the
to the decorator
yes the question is what kind of APO
easy no try them this is this is a basic
rich part yeah we have a phone I could
use
I mean the test storage is pretty simple
so there's no good reason to use a
trident ears yeah and the network layer
API is based on top Nettie Wedgwood open
source that net EDC MTP so it says run
cue protocol
of natty so basically you can schedule
tracks of 100 and send it to a remote
service once it's drawn you get a
callback
the callback puts the decorated data
like artist and album IDs back into the
queue thinking both ik acknowledged
upstream and also image the decorated
data to the to the downstream so that's
how works in a in a synchronous manner
it means it's it's we use this
particular pattern because all most of
all RPC vagaries a synchronous for some
cases like memcache and Cassandra most
of the libraries a synchronous are
blocking so there's no really need to do
that and then once you get track arias
and album ID and a bunch of other
information they get fed into the
listening trigger this is where the
interest part happening is happening
because you can trigger events based on
some kind of rule or pattern like if the
user searched for track and play it
that's interesting if the user
double-click something from someone else
playlist that's also interesting and in
we keep a running count of how many see
the same artists album or track in a row
and that's in memory and then we use
that to trigger repeats oh someone has
been jamming district four five times in
the last 30 minutes so and also this
that is a time there's a rate limiting
factor in it so we don't want to
generate too many stories from the same
user because otherwise you just becomes
boring so that's that's the listening
trigger next privacy sugar that's pretty
similar to the look at the metadata
lookup it's also a synchronous the only
difference here is we just saw some of
them away if the user has privacy turned
off we throw it away
and we also cache it so that we stop
processing the user for awhile but in
this case who only only cached the
privacy arm case because we want to want
it to be a consistent because in case
the user turned it off later
we will still catch the arm setting and
then we'll just keep sending users
private information what's the question
no right now it's pretty simple just
keeping a particular pattern like
reasons and the context and also the
repeats but this is where we can
experiment actually just by doing
something interesting or wisdom or m/l
but not ruining there's I mean there are
only like four or five fields so there's
no really need for complex through
injury yeah so this is a privacy but
that's pretty simple so at the end at
the anyway we have to publish the
message to somebody else again
whereas doing SOA so we have about
running somewhere it can be any of the
22 machines in the cluster but we have a
service discovery mechanism so this part
when it starts actually register itself
to the service discovery registry saying
hey I'm publishing on this machine at
this port so whoever wants my
information I just subscribe to it and
the feed service few services the
backend that serves data to user so he
looks it up from from the registry the
registry is based on DNS asabi it's
pretty simple old-school technology but
works so it creates a general 0 mq
socket to the pot and subscribe to the
events and of course you can scale this
up as well you can have multiple ports
running on many machines you can
duplicate the messages or balls
basically each bot have a 100% so if one
of them goes down you still get some
some level of redundancy and you can
have multiple subscriber to the same
part because it's a publishing based
mechanism so it's multicast to a lot of
different nodes we also have tools for
testing this so basically just saying
okay here's my service that's what the
name of the service and the tool just
hook it up and jump messages in real
time it's pretty it's a pretty nice way
for troubleshooting
storm application so any questions so
far
yes 0nq transport protocol
so there's a long queue it's I think
it's originally implementing C but we
really in Java so that and on top of
natty so that we can using all other
Java process services I mean there's
also jzm Q which is a Java process
talking through J and I to the C
implementation but then it's a little
bit harder to to troubleshoot you know
because there are so many interruptions
going on
yep we its first zero mu Q is basically
a nicer transport like a easier TCP
basically we still have to design our
own architecture like topology and all
that stuff yes Oh which one this one
okay I see cool that's anxious Thanks
you know when I interact with external
service right now it's mostly time out
cause I mean if there's an exception and
timeout and also a catch exception when
it happens which saw the event aware
which is okay so yeah I mean this case
this use case is not designed for
reliability it's designed for delivery
our availability yeah so we actually the
question is how to test their
applications where should we do it or
it's a JVM application so you can test
it locally we do that but we just
swapped a spot you know the input from a
Kafka spot to a replay like sample log
spot basically we go to a service
machine same hole let's say five solvent
events and then just play it back well
debugging you can do it in your in your
IDE or whatever tools you have by
running it locally
I mean if it's if there's some kind of
exception happening on a storm cluster
well you can either look at the storm UI
there's usually some exception logging
or in our case we actually also have
Kafka running on all the storm machines
so the error log actually gets delivered
to a centralized place where you can
grab or real-time to he'll like it's
another storm application that catches
Rome locks but yeah it works yes
a lot of car service I think we have six
in each data center just for collecting
local data center log and then we ship
it to the big Kafka which is like 20
machines there's latency I'm not a guy
walking on Kafka right now but it's more
like minute
if it's across Atlantic like from you
know us to the to the data center in
London it could be up to a minute
depending on the network condition yeah
we were using one point seven we're
upgrading on Oh on our way to upgrading
to 0.8 0.8 but then it breaks some
compatibility so I think some some one
the Kafka team is actually in Stockholm
so and someone's working on that right
now
yeah so yes right not just storm UI
storm all eight there's not much like
monitoring capability storm online has
metrics bill Qi we're gonna try that yet
but for our monitoring like for us as a
team building products we monitor the
user facing metrics so if the user
stopped receiving certain recommendation
that's a lot for us but not what's going
on with storm because that's that's just
the infrastructure piece so I mean that
the real event that should be attended
to the alert or incident that should be
attended to is the user facing events or
metrics yes I mean we monitor how many
tools were receiving from from a user
perspective
yeah our actually coverage in in the
next section
all right so let's move on to lessons
learned so far we don't launch of
lessons from using storm so first
development process it's still pretty
rudimentary right now we don't really
have any
well-defined process it's doing a
learning phase right sulphides one git
repository where each team puts
their own topology application in their
own folder subfolder and then we have a
sheared sub project which is the common
reusable parts like you know the cough
cast bouts or the or the main cache and
the decorator bolts that we discussed
before and then also as we discussed we
sample logs for local development and
every topology kind of follow the same
structure so it detects if you're
running in a local on a remote mode if
it's loquacious school pada spot with a
local log playback so it runs smoothly
locally and also we pulled all the
tunable parameters like parallelism and
JVM configuration and all those kind of
things into the config file and that's
pretty simple and for manufacturing
everyone working with JVM has seen this
before dependency hell and this is one
particular case where we depend on guava
stone actually uses a very ancient
version a koala 10 we ascribe a 14-4
some my own stuff and they have complex
earth complex so you get like mess on a
thorn or cosmo found problem in stone
and we actually you know instance Tony
you to build this you Bojo or like maven
shaded jar that contains everything you
need and he shipped it to the cluster
but then since storm that a JVM starts
strong first and allows the quality
actually oil precedes to over 14 you
using then you get an exception so our
solution is kind of hacky button works
we really relocate the guava 14 with the
mayonnaise jar there's a relocate
function basically just mingos the
bytecode and rename anything that's come
doc google or something - whatever class
pass or whatever package name you want
then they don't basically you have two
copies of the guava in the same
JVM and they don't conflict with each
other anymore that works for the world
for us
well we also use the same technique for
for job so we run on Hadoop like
scalding or on cascading yes
choices and a small factual has their
policy to use company policy to use
support Python and Java those
artificially the body language and those
actually fine for doing basic wiring
stuff like talking to any other JVM
libraries like Cassandra man cash cause
most of the popular choices in Java
anyway like as Danny acts for man cash
and it's a sorry ass Danny acts for
Cassandra
there's a spy man cash for the HD and we
have our own a PC library in Java
actually did up actually that the
previous storm topology has two versions
when in Java and why enclosure closures
maybe like two hundred lines of code in
one foul Java is maybe I don't know like
four or five files each like hundreds of
lines so closures more farm for doing
interesting algorithmic stuff because
it's so easy to just you know many page
data structures like maps lists and it's
it's a lot less overhead you actually
focus on the problem then how to the
right code actually works and another
thing we haven't tried edges Scala or
summing board something what is this
Twitter libraries that does patch and
real time in the same library so trailer
has scouting which is a pretty
high-level MapReduce code library and
something what is like that Bioworks
post on my produce and our storm so
that's something we wanted you to try
but we haven't found a use case yet but
then again our team has pretty good
scholar expertise I'm pretty sure we
should try that some point in the future
that's language choices and finally
deployment so right now we have one
shared cluster so everything is
popularized so we can just spin up new
machines through puppet pretty easily
the cost is sheared right now because we
don't really have that many jobs running
only fifteen and it's being fine and
also because we split the low so each
each technologies a lot less data to
process so if you if you remember before
we do log splitting Kafka
so each topology can just subscribe to
the particular type of message you're
interested in for example the listening
topology only subscribed to n sun-like
user playing a track if it's ads
targeting you might only keep track of
that plus ad impression so instead of
you know subscribing to the entire world
of every log message coming in source
qualify which is a lot which is like
terabytes a day and in the future think
the goal is to have stomp clusters per
team since it's all popularized it will
be easier to spin up new clusters and
maybe we can have it in multiple data
centers and finally we we have a young
cluster or Hadoop clusters actually
Hortonworks Hadoop 2.0 yeah and we have
a bunch of applications on here on like
spark but storm ions and something we
haven't tried yet mostly because we
don't have a use case and also there are
other considerations like firewalling
with production network and data
locality and stuff so those are the
things we haven't figured out yet and
then an answer the question of
monitoring where should we monitor it
from the from the user perspective so
this is a graph of a production server
and the number of listening stories
generally per second so think here
there's a network glitch so that's why
you must or all the traitors who join
the strike I know if you're always
window and that's actually that actually
trigger salons and mmm not so that's our
way of dealing with public tree
incidents you think that's it
thank you
also by the way we're hiring so check
all our jobs page and if you have more
questions talk to me
how's words anything I think we'll take
a few more questions I know yes okay
it's another resource yet another
resource I don't know what the n is for
negotiator okay so basically young as
the resource manager for Hadoop 2.0 so
in 1.0 everything is MapReduce basically
MapReduce figures out what notes you
need and what kind of data you want like
from HDFS and other stuff young age
Hadoop is actually did decoupled from
the resource management layer so
MapReduce becomes reproduce so MapReduce
becomes a application on yon but you can
also run other type of distributed
application on young like spark or storm
basically your application will have
some matzo no that runs on one of the
young nodes and then a negotiated with
the cluster like I need five hundred
machines with eight gigs of memory each
and young figure starts out and gives
you all these resources and then you
start your application and can be
anything can be again like MapReduce or
storm or even like old-school MPI and
stuff yes
how many machines on stone and what's
the next I think I have a slide before
we have 22 machines and we have a lot of
messages to attorney K per second that's
all the topologies combined so maybe one
of them will deal with I'd say 10,000
top two points per second they're
usually pretty small I mean the biggest
one is the incoming log message now
could be like a K or two because we have
a lot of field block messages like 100
different fields not not really because
most of the again most of the two posts
are pretty small once it gets through
the first layer of future it becomes
like two or three just the ones we want
I mean we always have a first party in a
chain that's a future that throws
anything else away yeah things pretty
standard like server hardware like 16 or
24 core and so D to get memory yeah so
pretty standard yeah yes some of you
about apologies did I talk I mentioned
some of these this is one but it's not
really interesting this is a very
interesting one the market track
basically keeping track of new users
coming in each market that's powered by
storm so basically we monitor like
real-time user registration and playback
and all that stuff and also which keeps
track of the users coming through each
different country market I mean these
are some of the ones most of them are
used for performance or user experience
tracking so they are not user facing
feature but we usually use them
internally to track all these sort of
metrics
yes the question is do we have situation
when we need to possess data or reliable
yes there are many different ways which
we have Cassandra and Postgres part like
at the end of your chain which just
writes to a database and if you think of
it listenings
topology and the end and the publishes
to other another service which is
started in Cassandra
so it's also persisted on disk let's go
back to that yes so this sorry this
topology here so eventually it goes to
the speed service and the field service
storage in Cassandra yeah yes yes we
monitored memory I actually have the
question is how do you monitor how many
parts and spots to useful for each layer
it's not a like hard specific like
science it's more like gut feeling and
just try an error I would say but I have
actually have access to the to the
cluster and I I know how much resource
my processors are running and also in a
storm you are you have latency for a lot
of the tuple processing for example some
of these like these parts that performs
external metadata lookup so seems to
attach in like patched patches of 100
requests within the same batch you can
actually track the tuple latency because
a tuple may not be process until the
batch restful so we just scaled it so
that we have reasonable trade-off
between latency and also the test report
and in some other cases like the
listening trigger which keeps a memory
cache of counter and stuff you can just
do like simple estimation of based on
our current user daily active users
that's like 10 million and then based on
any concurrent user at any point you
kind of estimate how much memory you
need on each machine
you handle all these these data so it's
a rough estimation but it works yeah in
that case we don't care if we if you
care you probably want to use a man cash
instead but then it increases the
latency so again it's trade off yeah yes
so the question is what are the some of
the problems with storm sync it's
missing oh it's not it's still like in a
you know like involving phase I would
say and it's missing some of the key
scenes I mean we would like to have like
for example monitoring or better
understanding of what your topology
object like tools for for tweaking a
topology and also the version we're
running it's not super stable like pods
sorry walkers goes on and off done like
up and down free often like it happen
once in a while so it's not exactly
stable yet but it works for our use case
for now yeah we haven't pressbox ringing
sounds really promising and well the
storm way of doing things since we're
still doing the basic like parts and
topologies just basically chaining them
together it's not as easy to develop
like complex machine learning algorithms
I would say spark on the other hand
gives you all really good abstraction of
you know you have this many many patch
swaps streaming you can just spark
streaming mode in Spock as well
basically you have this abstract data
model like a scholar correction and then
you can do all sorts of higher-order
function on top of it so that gives you
a lot of possibility for doing like
email updates and stuff so that's
something we want to try either that or
with something but in storm
like rostam yes it works very well for
the simple stuff you just want to build
a distributed system maybe interact with
some external service and you want to
process tuples but once you have some
complex business logic or ISM you wanna
you want to iterate on its it becomes a
little bit cumbersome to to think in
terms of bouts like what's each box
supposed to do whereas in spark where
you have a abstract data type you just
think of this is some idea how I'm gonna
transform it into something more useful
how I'm gonna loop through it applies on
some function and stuff so I think
that's the way we're looking at it yeah
yes yeah well it don't have to be other
questions how do you keep the America of
the listening for anything they don't
happy have to be in sync because when
the metadata yields a tuple to the
listener sugar actually are grouped by
the username so the same users events
always go to the same pouch so the each
part has you know information about one
single user or a group of users and they
don't have to be sync with each other
and it's a similar thing we're using
Pewabic hash
I mean it's pretty simple in memory but
has some nice functionality like kikyo
and exploration so it was pretty well
for us you know any other questions yes
sir
the storm is what the question is is
there any system level monitoring
actually the storm is a shared
environment we are not a team
administering the storm cluster we are
one of the few team developing
applications on top of storm but for
most qualified production machines we
have basic JVM memory like monitoring
and rules and if scenes happen these
trigger alerts to the to the SAR
operations team so we have some sort of
frame monitoring plan not enough how
they yeah think I can take one more
questions if there's any all right I
guess that's it then
thank you very much
[Applause]